on this episode we do the last episode
ever of the askgaryvee show in this
office hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is 219 of the
askgaryvee show listen I'm rusty I'm
rusty
this is an impromptu show my flight is
delayed I'm heading to Nashville
Tennessee I'm excited about that
we are moving vaynermedia's office as
you can see a lot of orange buckets this
is our last day in the office where this
show was originated and and I'm really
glad that the travel gods have imposed
an opportunity for us to film 2:19
there's a lot of people here it's hot I
don't know how to say the word episode
as you saw in the intro but I'm ready
India's acting a fool and and and you're
out of control we'll see
all right Pierce you get to ask the
first question I'm down on belts I
haven't worn a belt in a long time I
don't believe in belts I don't like them
you I do have my pants today what you
like it yeah thank you thank you thank
you
all right Pierce go do something
productive thanks for the bail question
in your rusty ru let's get into the show
ready let's let's get into the show the
show again the Shah nope again the show
there we go all right ru I know that's a
shotgun episode and you weren't fully
prepared Tyler who is it
Ethan Ethan ass should I be working 18
hours a day in episode 215 you said that
putting in the time does not
you'll be successful I'm confused should
I give that um Ethan Ethan it works both
ways look here's my point about hard
work that's a great opportunity to like
it's a great way they're like be in this
spot and then as we move to the next
office like hard work really matters but
let's talk about it both ways yes an
episode 215 or whatever I said it that
it doesn't like if you put in 18 hours
day and you don't have talent you will
not get results if you put in 9 hours a
day and you are loaded with talent and
whatever you're doing you will get
results
so it's this cross-section of work ethic
and talent they both matter people get
so mad when I talk about talent we added
that whole Cruella episode where I was
like that whole debate and in the
comments a bunch of you losers yep
losers we're like no you can make it
happen if you work hard enough that is
just not true stand up everybody in the
comment section if you worked very hard
for three four five six seven years at
something and you didn't get the
greatest results of all time and have a
white picket fence and hit the Hall of
Fame it happens every day but talent is
not something that you watching this
right now can go home and say I'm gonna
muster up more talent in art in business
in sports you can't do that but work
ethic you can and so I push work ethic
because I believe it's a variable and I
believe it's far more controllable I do
believe that you can cut out leisure
change your mindset and put in the work
I do not believe that you automatically
can become unbelievably millionaire
status world-class of what you do do I
think you can become a better editor if
you do it a bunch I sure do do I think
you could be better at tennis if you
like play a lot yes I do do I think that
means that you could be on the tour no I
do not park your ass
we know you're not a green green guy but
be honest how many nike kicks you got
actually answered him on Twitter
the answer was 20 until I hung out on my
boy DJ Clue last night who hooked me up
with like 20 pairs of Air Force that's
unbelievable he's the greatest guy and
he just gave this I'm wearing this
ferrets new so now I have 40 like
literally double my collection he just
had 20 that's how he wrote he's a
gangster man he's been he has like 40
pairs of the same stuff I guess he's the
best obviously a good friend and
actually asked him to be on the show
last night
we're hanging out so DJ Clue iconic
hip-hop DJ will be coming through soon
Blake Blake ass what are your thoughts
on breaking out in the world of politics
and branding the right way you know
politics things been very interesting
it's been very much on my mind is it
probably is for most people in the UK in
the u.s. with all the things going on in
those countries and probably a lot of
other places but what I'm familiar with
you know the truth is if I was born in
America I really really really would run
for president eight years like I'm not
even joking uh you know but I wasn't and
so I'm not and I don't want to be the
governor so do I think politics is a
place of opportunity for a lot do I
think that politics has clearly in last
10 years because of social media because
the way the world works because of where
the environment in the u.s. politics
landscape sits that I do I think that
there will be a lot of people who can
use media to give themselves a real shot
and make mayor governor senator
president campaigns of course it's been
proven and so I think it's gonna be a
very intriguing 50 years in politics
because I do believe the landscape
change everything I believe in marketing
and business deploys to society it the
issues were dealing with racism we're
gonna have to look at everything that
we're about to live through an
unbelievable time in human race because
all in this with five cameras going
right now like I like 10 people stopped
me today the Iraq like there's so much
going on there's a lot going on and I'm
just showing a blueprint like I've
always done so many of you are starting
to feel the effects of this I see it I'm
getting a lot more emails and social
media content from you guys of results
that are happening for you eBay people
that are making tons of money people
that are vlogging people that are you
know
musically busting out their influence or
marketing there's there's something in
the air Sam Sam ass how do you find your
motivation again after dealing with
grief and loss Sam I don't feel
comfortable in answering questions and
I'm not in a position to answer and the
truth is I have not dealt and this is
why I'm probably so happy to be a 40
years old and have the unfortunate
situation of not having three of my four
grandparents when I was born
well two one died before I can remember
him I just have been very lucky and I I
would tell you that I'm gonna make you
one promise
your grandfather is not heartbroken it's
only been eight weeks life is very long
you know grandfather knew that best and
I don't think he would judge you in an
eight week window I think you should
properly grieve and I do think it's a
gut punch
I think it's appropriate heck I
sometimes don't hustle for six to 12 to
24 hours after a Jets loss and that's
silliness right so for you to be
appropriately morning I think is great
and I think you should not put pressure
on yourself and I think you should let
your emotions run their course some
eventually you have to get back in the
saddle that's just the way it is but I
don't think you should pressure on
yourself at two months for sure let
alone maybe even six months but I'm sure
to get back on the grind in no time and
and I really appreciate the kind words
and I'm sorry for your loss
last one the last question in the river
light the light again even more I'm
frustrated you look frustrated I'm just
go the airport livestream for five
straight hours
we might be need to we might be in
trouble with that flight because I could
get cancelled as it gets get pushed so
can you like start looking for
alternatives looks like we're going
private do you rock
remember how fancy is we forgot how they
we haven't done this in so long you
super fancy guys I'm gonna try and tell
you well he's right you've abandoned us
go ahead what's that son Night Music so
just three random words together okay
look at respects or eccentric good son
my ass what was your best day at the old
office that was a question
you guys made that up that was just
sitting there oh it just got happened
resume fit what is oh that's a great
question what was the question
my best moment right you know what this
is actually the true answer and I think
it's app Wow good job I'm so pumped we
did a little periscope before we went on
to get the question I'm so pumped with
this answer cuz it's the truth and I
think it's very it's romantic it's a
good story no question the best day in
this office for me ever was the first
day because we were crammed who's there
you were there in the in the old office
nope see oh gee yep maybe you're
slightly getting back into the fan um we
were cramped as you remember and we
moved here and it was so big remember
everybody was like oh my god it's so
nice and there's so much room the views
and all this and so to sit here when did
we move here like 2 and 1/2 years ago
oh really like three years ago
so that first day I was proud that what
AJ and I and the rest of team were
building created an environment that was
good and an exciting and brought value
to my teammates the people that helped
all this happen and so as you guys will
find out on Monday because I'm sure
we'll edit a really cool askgaryvee show
and add a levy that really shows off our
new office we are leveling that up and
as you know some of you that watched on
livestream when Meg Dedes doing her call
sitting outside
I mean people been doing meetings and
broom closets and and I love that by the
way I love the the ghetto nature of that
I never I'm actually very worried about
the new move and ever
get real fancy I think like andis gonna
wear tie or something but uh but uh but
the best day was the best day was the
first day because the look in
everybody's eyes of you know it's funny
they were looking at me as like thank
you for like making this happen and I
just remember thinking thank you for
making this happen in return I think
that's what's gonna happen on Monday in
a couple days I think everybody's gonna
be thank you and oh my god her the
cafeteria is insane
you've seen it thanks for the video
thing was was it amazing yeah
fired up so I still haven't seen it
that's the funniest part of everything
and then Tyler and you're gonna screw my
office you dealt with that earlier
anyway I I would say that and so uh
vaynernation um I will see on Monday in
a new setting which wasn't isn't it me
fully built out but we have like a new
little mike is my office gonna be we're
gonna fill and you can do like a whole
bookshelf you're gonna do some really
clever you guys have a real plan really
why'd you tell me that I would have been
good surprise he ruins everything
question of the day what is your
favorite move of location so far in your
life you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them